قبل اكثر من شهر بقليل اصبحت تويتر ملفا
مثيرا للجدل كرئيسه تنفيذي الى الماسك منذ
ان اشترى ماسك الموقع لم يغيب اسم تويتر
عن عناوين الاخبار ويبدو ان التصرفات ماسك
باتت تنظر بمزيد من العنف على العصفور
الازرق مسؤولون امريكيون اطلقوا تحذيرا
ينظر بالضروره تجنب مزيد من العنف قد
يساهم فيها العصفور الازرق خلال الاشهر
المقبله واستشهدوا بانتشار المحتوى
المتطرف بما في ذلك دعم النازيين للعباده
الجماعيه من قبل مشاهير ومتابعين على نطاق
واسع مع ظهور دعاه يناصرون العنصريه
واوضحوا ان ماسك كان اصدر عفوا واسعا عن
معظم الحسابات المحظوره في سابقا وتفعل
شخصيا مع
نشاطرون افكارا عنصريه على الموقع في
الاسابيع التي توليه ملكيه الدوله